is you guess you all know me so good
actually well that this is joint work
very recent during work actually with my
student naman agarwal and my half
student feedback madam he's a full
person but he has another advisor like
typically so okay yeah he's a full
person very smart one to both of them
okay so this talk is about expander
graphs and the general sort of layout of
the talk would be as follows first I'm
going to tell you a little bit what
expand the graphs are probably you
already know but i'll give you the point
of view of myself and the field then
lift of graphs where r lifts of graphs
originally little grass were used
suggested to construct expand the graphs
therefore i'm going to describe what
they are and then so some results about
to lift and generally small list of
graphs that prove that most of them are
indeed expanding and thus this is the
right way were one of the right ways to
go in order to construct expander graphs
and give some open questions in the area
so expand the grass are great we all
love them and have been in the last few
decades have had numerous applications
in almost all areas of computer science
you know to name a few design algorithms
error correcting codes randomness
extractors pseudo-random generators
sorting networks other more striking
applications in complexity theory the
proof that l equals SL / angle or the
new proof of the PCP theorem Biden or
etc so the moral of this slide and the
story in general is that expansion is
good therefore we seek ways of achieving
high expansion efficiently we as in
computer scientists and the standard
there's three standard sort of
literature ways where we can see what
expanders are there is a community
oriole definition of expansion where you
could look at cuts or sets and see how
much they expand what what are the edges
the god of this set the other is the
linear algebraic
point of view where we look at the
eigenvalues of these graphs and i want
to say what's the spectral gap one large
spectrograph I'll define what that is in
a second and the third one is
probabilistic so we want random walks on
expand the graphs converts rapidly I
guess we want random walk some graphs to
convert its rapidly expander sativa so
really briefly the community definition
of expansion what it does it takes a
graph G and set the graph is said to be
epsilon expanding if for all subsets of
the vertices let's say less than half of
the number of nodes the number of edges
that go out of the subset is
proportional to epsilon times the size
of a set and in this ends with the
standard definition of ed's expansion
its expansion this H of G parameter of
the graph it's just the minimum over all
cuts s and s prime of the edges that
cross the cut over the size of the
smaller side of the cup and for the
spectral definition which is what we're
going to be interested in for this talk
and they're very related the two let's
let's define some things first look at
the adjacency matrix of g and n by n
matrix it has n real eigenvalues and
let's order them in decreasing order
lambda 1 through lambda n we're only
going to be dealing for this talk for
the regular graphs because traditionally
expanders where d regular graphs i mean
there's some sort of new works with
specification editor that try to
construct non-regular expanders but
let's just focus on the regular graphs
in which case lambda 1 is always d and
if the graph is bipartite lambda n is
also minus d we call those to the
trivial i can buy you so those are
always going to be standard and known
and what we really care about what
parameter we really care about is what
we call lambda so this lambda is defined
to be the maximum absolute value of all
the other eigenvalues there are none of
the trivial ones if your graph is known
by part ivan lambda is also included
there
so lambda is just how big can any other
eigenvalue them a trivial one can be in
magnitude and spectral grab we refer
just the gap between the first and the
second eigenvalue in this case d minus
lambda 2 and something we're going to
use a bit later if we want to define
spectral radius this is just the highest
absolute agony of a matrix so in this
particular case it would be D ok alright
so here is what expanders are and in the
spectral sense it's quantified largely
by the following theorem which is also
known as Tiggers inequality it says that
what we just saw before the ads
expansion is closely related to the
spectral gap in fact it's between the
minus lambda 2 over 2 and square root to
the D minus lambda 2 it's a very useful
theorem that has led to many beautiful
algorithms okay so now since we're
convinced that Specter expanders and
that expanders for us are both very
important and are very similar in nature
let's see how much expansion can we
expect and let's see that in terms of
the spectral gap now so expanders for me
or large spectrograph graphs from now on
okay so we want expansion we want it to
be a spectrograph we want it to be as
big as possible how much how big can
that be well there is a theorem by
ilaignan bopanna very well-established
theorem that says that unfortunately no
matter how much a try for any d regular
graph I cannot get lambda 2 to be any
smaller than 2 D minus 1 minus some
little of one that goes to 0 as n goes
to infinity so this is as good as it
guess this is how much I can hope for
and the question now becomes is that
something that's achievable in that
light let's define ad regular graph
Ramanujan if this is achievable if
lambda is less than or equal to 2t minus
1 and it's sort of normal these days to
define stuff Kwazii polynomial Kwazii
exponential
the Ramanujan those would incorporate
some constant factors or around constant
factors okay so here comes the important
question that a lot of computer
scientists have asked well it's easy to
see that Ramanujan grass exists in very
small very small number of notes take
complete graph on D plus 1 nodes it's
reminiscent great but this is not very
useful for applications you know if you
wanted to build large fault tolerant
networks or something so the question is
can we find arbitrarily large reminders
and graphs a series of grass that grows
with n they're all Romans this question
was answered the answer is yes and first
margulies lebowski phillips and czarnik
and then Morgan's 10 with an extension
of their theorem constructed sets graphs
for all n the caveat here is that the
degrees of such graphs were known so far
to exist was the Wendy minus 1 is a
prime number so this was in the 80s and
in fact this is the only construction of
Ramanujan graphs this group of
constructions I guess is the only
construction of Ramanujan graphs known
to this day so we don't know how to
construct such graphs for any degree
different than such that D minus 1 is a
prime okay however there are some things
that we do know one is a celebrated
result by Friedman that showed that
random d regular graphs are almost
reminiscent with very high probability
so okay it's really hard to find them
but if you really just sample sample
randomly boom you just get our manage
and grab almost with some small epsilon
which is great but still doesn't tell me
how to find them and then there is a
recent break I think it depends on d
I don't think it depends on these
whatever you I'm goes to 0 with that
that's it hmm i'm not entirely sure
about that no names are sufficiently
like you didn't really yeah i think
absolutely is a constantly depends on d
what's stopping you from be okay they
may be exponential or something indeed
yeah how many good fine yeah I didn't me
like a function and I equal to D or
something I meant there yeah okay fine
one over to the Dean or worn over to do
the two to the D or somewhere you know
yes Gil said is with like fifty two
percent the graph will not be yeah so
I'll get to that in a second that it's
not whether the relation for every thing
this is not true experimentally I mean
it's not proved people you should be
about this is fifty-three percent
conjecture no but is not with high
permeability this result holds with
exponentially high probability in in n
so if you take a n vertex D regular
graph with probability exponentially
small in and this is not rather with
probability 1 minus exponentially small
in n this whole tournament
asymptotically going to 0 with it so I'm
sorry I'm not I don't know exactly
Friedman's parameters right now but with
extremely high permeability a random the
regular graph is almost Ramanujan in
fact this has been improved with I'm
going to mention a bit later by puter
that showed plus one here by door on
puter in you there I don't know how you
pronounce his last name puter so we can
resolve freely show that that's true for
every epsilon bigger than 0
sugar so that is somewhat shorter proof
right so it is more global proof that
includes what I'm going to talk about
next but let me get to that in a second
so so this this happens and in fact it's
one of the open questions what is the
probability that the graph is exactly
Ramanujan which I'm going to get to in
the end but what happened recently with
probably most of you have heard this
talk by that egg sorry nikhil was here
by a result by marcus film and surest
episode that reminisce on graphs exists
for every degree this was an existential
proof though and still didn't give any
construction nor did they sort of say
what probability you know you can find
them or anything like that there was by
friedman again a suggestion that came a
few years back that just like we build
expanders from small expanders by
performing some operation he suggested
why don't we take a good expander and
lift it so create a graph lift and hope
to get a good expander the suggestion
was sort of implicit in one of these the
first paper that proved relative
expanders with lifts so let me define
what lifts of graphs are by picture
hopefully and that should be enough but
we'll see so here's the base graph three
nodes and AK lift of a graph let's take
a equals three it's a graph that has
three times or K times in general as
many nodes as the base graph so every
place each one of the nodes by three
copies and let's number them 1 2 3 first
call the second copy third coffee and I
replace every edge with a matching
between these sort of blocks of nodes so
in this particular lift we have replaced
every edge with the identity matching or
identity permutation you can identity
labeling you can call it as you wish
where the first copy of each of the
vertices is connected with each other in
this lift we've replaced only the purple
edge with the identity and the rest with
some other matching some other
permutation so
is what lifts are for general k and more
formally we have if we take a base graph
G the lift has K times as many nodes ok
for each vertex of G and we define this
sort of K nodes as a fiber of the vertex
V and every edge XY is replaced by
permutation and matching however you
want to call it that connects the
corresponding copies of these fibers
indicated by the permutation by the way
for those of you who know unique games
conjecture this should sound very
familiar and I'll talk about the
connection there if I have some time and
you know the opposite ads just take the
inverse permutation early YX heads take
the inverse permutation k would be the
degree of the lift not to be confused
with a degree of the graph I know it's a
bit click similar notation G is called
the base graph aids the lifted graph for
the rest of the talk and what we mean by
random lives is if we fix the base graph
fix AK and choose each one of the
permutations for the edges uniformly at
random depending on how you choose them
from what set but let's say now from sk
the set of permutations of K elements
this is a random lift if you choose its
permutation from the set of six
permutations of K elements this is a
random shift k lift etc etcetera so
random lift in general you choose permit
only the permutation choice is the
random part ok and easy observation we
don't need to worry about the degree of
the graph because it remains de regular
if original graph was the regular ok so
since we use lifts to we want we don't
yet but we want to use lifts to
construct expanders let's see what
happens with expansion of the lifts so
here are some elementary observations a
lift cannot have a better edge expansion
than the base graph why is that we take
any set on the base graph I'll give you
a set with the same expansion just take
all the K copies of the vertices in the
set both the edges and
vertices increase by a factor of K
therefore expansion cannot it cannot be
better in the lift and it can also be
shown that it cannot be much like it
cannot be horrible if you take a large
enough here's what happened with EDS
expansion but we are dealing with
spectral expansion right now and let's
see what what happens there here's an
easy but important observation the
original agin values of adjacency matrix
of the graph G are also augen values of
adjacency matrix of the lift why is that
that's easy to see take an eigenvector f
of the base graph and for each vertex V
let's say fov was the value of the
eigenvector just now copy this value for
all each one of the K vertices in the
fiber so now this like this new F prime
a green vector has constant value on its
fiber and equal to F of V it's easy to
see that this is an eigenvector of the
adjacency matrix of the lifted graph as
well with the same exact eigen value so
this eigen values that already belong to
G we call them old again values because
sort of there's no hope for them there's
nothing you can do about him yeah
they're doomed and we call the new
eigenvalues the hopeful ones the ones
that we can they want that we can hope
to improve to to say something about ok
so what we learn from this previous
slide is that the spectral gap can also
not increase since lambda 2 of GX it
like lambda 2 Z is an eigenvalue of of
the lift therefore we cannot hope to get
better lambda 2 but what we can hope is
to not get much worse or do not get
worse at all so what we would like to
show and what Friedman started trying to
argue about 30 years back no not quite I
think would like to keep the new
eigenvalues bounded by actually there
are managed and bound if possible so
fine we sacrifice lambda 2 of Z we have
it we can't do anything about it but
all the other eigenvalues are bounded by
2 D minus 1 or something around there
then we can essentially preserve the
expansion of the base graph when we lift
and if we can do the above then we have
a good algorithm to produce large
arbitrary larger management graphs
here's the algorithm start with a
smaller Madison graph KD + 1 let's say
the cliq lifted since the expansion
doesn't change or the spectrograph
doesn't change hope this is an
assumption that this new eigenvalues are
bounded by two in t minus one and you
cannot do better than that so start with
a 3-1 expander lift it repeat can do
that as many times as possible you can
get arbitrarily good expanders
arbitrarily large good extenders ok any
questions so far this is it i'll get to
that but this is if we knew but a
specific in a way to lift gives you to
redo minus 1 eigen values and we could
do that forever even at random we could
do that if we knew what I'm talking
about right but the point I'll talk
about all of this in a second okay so
here is what has happened so far until
this result on lifts and most of the
things have happened in the regime where
K is large the K tends to infinity with
its larger for example the number of
note than the number of nodes of the
graph and the result that I'm going to
present in this slide hold with high
probability in K so you need to argue to
have a and lift or more when n is the
number of nodes of the graph for the
following results to be true so Friedman
in the paper that have been mentioning
showed that all the new eigenvalues of
any base graph are bounded with high
probability by order d to the three
quarters if K goes to infinity with n
then linear and put ur improved that to
do to the two-thirds order of D to the
two-thirds their ebay and griffiths
improved to order of square root d now
we're getting close and finally puter
given
almost ultimate result of two Rudy minus
one plus one which generalizes yeah I'll
get it's not because this is for large
lips oh yeah so I'll get the small lips
in a second you always go like two
slides ahead okay so here's what we know
for k equals large and this is great I
mean we know almost everything now we
know the newegg in values are almost
reminders on okay we don't need much
more but why look at anything else well
here's why I look at anything else
because okay finally tell your random
and lift is almost ramanujan expander
would go ahead and the randomized it if
you want I mean good luck with that
there is not much hope to to do
something it's just like saying okay
construct and expanded from random
random d regular graphs already so we
would like to look at cake or small
possibly k goes to and prove something
similar like can we saw that for any
base graph two lifts are with high
probability expanding and then there is
hope there is a there is a way I mean
not an exact way to construct Ramanujan
grass but billion lineal have a way to
give good good expanders from sat slaves
there are many issues here but let me
say first what billion lineal actually
did do what they said is ok if we take
to lift for any base graph there exist
had to lift such that all the new advice
are bounded by this rudy log 3d so sorry
square root d block 3d this is an
existential result it can extend to hold
with hyper ability on the number of
vertices of the graph if the base graph
is a good expander but it doesn't say if
we take Eddie based graph with high
probability all the new eigenvalues are
order ruth d log 3d because it can say
that and we'll see why and in fact this
breakthrough i was talking about that
showed that Ramanujan graphs of all
degrees exist went with two lifts for
the proof that there existed to lift for
every graph that has exactly there
bound okay so all of those result are
really great and they advanced the field
of expanders but none of them says what
happens with high probability I mean
except for this sort of semi high
probability statement none of it says
what happens on average if you take two
lifts nor do we know how to find
actually a good lift with the exception
again of billion lineal that extended
this proof to a construction which still
gives the log 3 so the square root log
3d factor which is sort of unwanted if
you want to construct Ramanujan
expanders ok so let let me show you what
the results that I want to talk about
our I'm going to talk about results on 2
lists and k-lift in general for sift k
lifts for any k and also a nice
byproduct of all of those would be a
complete characterization of the eigen
values of K shift lifts so let me
present this ugly picture now which is
the theorem that I want to talk about so
what we show in this paper is that if G
is at the regular graph and all its
non-trivial i'll give a use our atmos
lambda in absolutely and let H be a
uniformly random to lift of g and london
you be the largest in absolute value
eigen value of H then this is bounded by
order of lambda so we don't have any log
D factors we don't have any assumptions
on the base graph so if the base graph
is Ramanujan if it's a click the plus
one this could be order of root d minus
one now Rudy I guess doesn't matter if
you have the order and this happens with
high permeability in the number of nodes
of the graph and we get something
stronger if the graph is expanding but
I'm not going to talk about this and a
similar thing holds for k6 lists for any
k very similar thing in fact exactly the
same just the probability changes and
i'll explain why those two things are
essentially the same thing but let me
first remind you what we saw but London
News order of lambda order of the London
yeah
not at the moment yeah okay so this is
this is the result that I'm talking
about from now on um but let's first see
if how optimal is this result I mean we
saw before billion lineal showed through
the log 3d which is clearly not optimal
because we get something stronger but is
this optimal can we get Ramanujan can we
get something better so there are two
possible places where theorem these
theorems could be improved one place is
the dependency on lambda as we saw in
the large lift case there is no
dependency on the base graph we said any
base graph take it take an end lift at
random it's almost Ramanujan can that
happen here and the answer is no
suspense okay the answer is no why is
the answer now it can relatively easily
be shown that for example if you start
with a disconnected base graph let's
take another ad plus 1 copies of KD + 1
then a random to lift of it with high
probability has new eigen value equal to
lambda equal to D so we cannot hope to
get any Ramanujan bound that does not
depend on the eigen value of the base
graphical so have very little randomness
I mean some sense taking and lift skills
the base graph like it's so much bigger
but here we can show that with high
probability they still exist one that's
Ramanujan but with high probability most
of them are actually disconnected so
dependency on lambda is necessary then
the second place that we could look at
this combat constant become 22 Rudi
minus 1 instead of order or rather can
it become lambda a new less than or
equal to lambda rather than less than or
equal to order of lambda and
experimentally you know damn Spillman
has run and nikhil has run some
experiments that so that about half of
the laser actually Ramanujan and some of
them are not so we can't really do that
with high probability either so I mean
yeah we can improve our constant right
now which is not the best maybe it's
like a thousand million something
I don't know why I don't know don't even
remember what the constant is but we
cannot really improve morally much in
that sense so in that sense I result is
optimal okay so now I'm gonna
unfortunately the proof is really ugly
and has very very scary formulas I'm
going to try to sketch a little bit what
happens and how to prove that in the
last 15 minutes I have a bunch of time
okay so here is the proof of theorem 1
it says what happens with to lift a
amazing fact about two lifts and as it
turns out about case shift lifts which
was given to us was known and it's
actually easy to observe is that these
are equivalent to signings of the graph
what I mean by signing well take a graph
sine its edges randomly or however you
want with plus and minus 1 signs and
let's denote a s of G the signed
adjacency matrix which instead of one
wonders and ed's i have now the sign
minus 1 or 1 and its immediate to
observe that a to lift and assigning are
the same thing I mean they're equivalent
why we'll take a signing and let's say
the sign of EDS XY was one then I put
the identity permutation as a matching
between the fiber of X and the fiber of
Y and if the sign of EDS XY would be
minus one then I would put the cross
permutation maybe let me draw that do we
have these ads and here's the
corresponding part of the to lift if
sine of X Y is 1 then this is what
happens to my left and if sine of X Y is
minus 1 what happens to my left so its
immediate to construct one from the
other and this is great for us because
now we know exactly what are the
eigenvalues of the lift there are the
eigenvalues of a as we saw before of G I
mean the adjacent matrix of G Union the
egg invite
is of the adjacency matrix of the
signing so the complete set of
eigenvalues of lift are characterized by
these two matrices and this is easy to
see this is like a sketch of the proof
if you when we saw the the fact that
eigen values of dr eigenvalues of the
lift prior to the slide and now let's
see that eigen values of the signed
identity matrix are also i can rise to
the left and what we do is we observe
that the lift adesso matrix is just this
block matrix that has a plus a s and the
diagonals and a minus a s in the off
diagonals and if you was an eigenvector
of a s then u minus u is an eigenvector
of this matrix with the same eigenvalue
in fact two times the previous
eigenvalue but two cancels out with that
so the eigen values of the lift sardegna
bites of the signs matrix are also i can
values for the lift so now if we wanted
to bounce anything about the new
eigenvalues of the lift we need to look
at one thing the spectral radius of a s
which is the largest eigen value of a s
it makes our life pretty easy because
instead of dealing with big matrices I
guess twice as big now we deal with one
matrix and only the spectral radius we
don't need to consider lambda 2 s or
lambda trees or anything like that okay
so what we hope to show to prove theorem
one is to show that the spectral radius
of a random signing is with a
probability bounded by something
proportional to L of G so and this is
the spectral radius by definition so let
me try to describe really quickly what
Billy lineal did just to prove the
existence of a lift of Rudy log 3d
here's what they did they used a very
important lemma which called the
converse of X fun mixing lemma all it
says is it says take a real and by n
symmetric matrix zeros on the diagonal
kind of like an adjacency matrix looking
thing and you know and one norm of its
row is at most D if for all 0 comma 1
vectors
this holds so the ratio they're almost
the Rayleigh quotient and it's not
exactly really caution but and with this
holds the this ratio is bounded by alpha
then we can argue that the spectral
radius of a loses a factor of log D over
alpha but it's bonded around alpha love
the overall so they use that in this way
they show fix u and v belonging to 01 or
i get 0 1 minus 1 but this is a
technicality so that with high enough
probability this hold so this ratio is
bounded by order Rudy lagdi and now you
can see where the log 3 to the third D
comes from because you saw that this
happens then use love as local Emma to
argue that there exists a single signing
that for all UV the same exact signing
gives you this order Rudy log D ratio
and then conclude by the converse of
expanded mixing Emma that I just showed
you that by another log D factor loss
the spectral radius of a s is order of
whatever we had here x log D which turns
out to be that so this is their approach
and in fact this theorem is beautiful
like the converse that they showed in
this paper however it has a bit a couple
of caveats as you know for our purposes
the one is that there are two places
where we lose a log D I guess a route
logged in an actual lumpy which is
pretty bad and then this proof cannot
provide high probability bounds thank
you if that cannot happen from this way
of arguing so we need a really more
delicate analysis and a lot more things
to happen for the theorem to come
together so here is what we we do to
remedy this problem remember we need an
upper bound on the spectral radius of a
sign adjacency matrix so look at the
fixed vector X and just right round it
down or up to a vector that looks like
plus minus 1 over 2 to VI and it's easy
to so that we can lose a factor of 4 and
approximate the spectral radius of a s
with just
looking at vectors of this form then we
consider the Datak the composition of
wine two vectors that means that you I
is sort of a 0 1 minus 1 vector that had
one over two to the i coordinate and we
easily write Y in this form and you can
see that this sum is just the sum over
all I days of the corresponding terms
bear with me in this couple of slides I
said they were ugly let's look at an
individual term in this inner product
and one of the UI and UJ so fix I and J
and look at it and s remember is there
signing that now we choose a random so
over random choices of the siding this
term is just the sum of independent
zero-mean random variables and easily we
can apply off the book turn off bound
and prove that in fact the absolute
value of this term cannot be much larger
than real deal of the times the supports
of of the vectors here as use the
support of a vector and this is so far
what Billy Lily are used in their proof
that's the first part of the proof and
here is there there are two immediate
problems here the log D and this support
if the support is small the probability
is not enough so here's how we remedy
the high probability problem well very
obviously we look at small sets of sets
of small support separately so when the
support of you I games they are small
then we just put a trivial bound and
bound this by lambda norm of Y squared
not with high probability always this is
just a completely trivial one that
always holds and in fact I want to draw
the attention again to lambda we argued
before that lambda the dependency on
lambda cannot be avoided and this is
another place where we see that because
for small sets we can see on the base
graph the edges that go out of small
sets are governed sort of Pi Lambda if
you look at expander mixing lemma okay
so this is the second place where we see
that we really need lambda but
the nice thing about this is once we get
rid of this small support said then we
have high permeability so that's fine we
resolve this problem however we still
need to to to resolve the log D problem
which is the harder problem and here's
what we do remember this sum that we
have this dyadic terms and you know the
number of terms in the sum is edges
between the supports of these two
vectors at most and let's approximate
them user using expander mixing lemma so
now this will use this as a bound on the
number of terms in the sum and just to
remind you i'll probably all of you know
but this is expander mixing lemma it
argues that for any graph the number of
edges between any two subsets are close
to what happens in a random graph and
close governed by lambda so this is
expander mixing lemma ok so we use this
this thing to approximate the terms in
the sum and we we look at two cases on
which term of the expander mixing glam
approximation dominates the other so the
first case is when this is smaller than
this so one term dominates the other
let's go back to the Chernoff bound that
we had with a log defector loss we need
the tighter bound clearly on the
deviation of this term because otherwise
you know we're done so instead of log D
we just use log D times the ratio of the
supports and here's what we get with
high probability I'm just flashing this
here it's really ugly and I apologize
for that but this is turns out to be
well yeah this turns out to be exactly
what we need for the Union bound to work
and now for all the terms I'd say sets
that this term dominates the other we
can give the Union bound and argue that
with high probability everything works
and I want to note that here is an
important point that one of the problems
that Billy lineal had is that when sui
and suj were different in size very
different then is when they get like a
big problem in discrepancy and the log
de factor
was one of the place that it came up so
this takes care of this discrepancy by
adding the ratio ok so case too is when
the other term double dates the other
well there is another hidden case in
there where we can deal with easily when
I and J are far apart but just three
will bond again that holds always but so
let's look at I and J close together
there the remedy we found for this for
this part is instead of looking at each
term of the sum we look at a sum of
terms to sort of convert the sum of
square roots to a square root of a some
type of thing and again if we didn't use
this sum then its term would be counted
lagdi times or a half log D times and
then we would get along the factor of
loss and this is the second ugly thing
that we get for this or beautiful I
guess thing that we get for this for
this case I guess I have a few minutes
so let me put everything together and
wait you get the proof I'm not gonna I
don't want to go more into this proof
because it's mostly after these three
observations and remedies its
calculations and they work out I do want
to say what happens with a
generalization of the case if lifts
because this is something that I think
it's pretty beautiful actually so now a
shift lift is what you expect to be
instead of choosing any permutation
between adds their fiber of x and y it
is a six permutation this is for the
unique game sort of notation X minus y
equals C mod gay but a constraint of
this form okay so these are sift listen
to lift is a specific case of a shift
lift and let me remind you what worked
for us why was it like good too why were
we able to argue about this nagging
values of to lift was because we knew
what the eigen values where we had to
look at the adjacency matrix of the sine
graph and bounded spectral norm spectral
radius okay can we say the same thing
for K lifts there is no such at least
car currently or previously there is no
such characterization however let me
define a generalized type of signing so
let's pick a parameter T for now and for
each edge of the graph G let's sign it
by one power of T so 2 to the 0 1 2 K
minus 1 if we have a que shift lift and
let's call a parametrized by T to be the
signs adjacency matrix it turns out that
the eigenvalues of the lift adjacency
matrix for k sifts are exactly the union
of the eigenvalues of a Omega where
Omega is the K through the view nity so
we have K different matrices K times n
eigen values each k times and anybody's
give the complete spectrum of the lifts
and now our job becomes easy because all
we need to do is to bound the spectral
radius of each of those matrices
separately and we get the same result
pretty much with the same argument I
mean in fact we prove this and then to
lift is a special case ok so I have a
couple of minutes for open questions and
if you have any questions ask me but I'm
gonna move to future directions so far
do the what
oh I mean it depends on how you left
right you could take the identity left
in them you have disconnected copies of
the same graphic I'm not entirely sure
yeah so the main open questions that I
found and I mean in fact a few of them
are the reason why we got there with
this result is what percentage of lives
is exactly Ramanujan is it 51% that
expect I don't know fifty two percent or
something else I don't know we can't
there is no clear methodology to argue
about when is something exactly
Ramanujan right now then a similar
question if you start from any base
graph how likely is it that you get
exactly lambda in the lift we we don't
know how to say that but if we did that
would be great and the main question
that all of this sort of business
started from is how can we use this to
build good expanders we even at the
moment don't know how to use this to
build expanders with order of lambda
loss because Billy lineal the log D
factor there allowed them to actually
turn it to a construction but if we
don't have the log D factor we can't
even turn it into a construction right
now so we don't know how to build
expanders from this at all okay thanks
so what about bounds
the first one to argue that it's at
least to review something you have a
similar bound for the largest new
eigenvalue lived does it also happy yeah
i think joel friedman in one of these
papers that i mentioned has it see their
very centre of his or I mean he
definitely has a bound on one of his
previous papers but I think I was
talking to him a few months ago and he
mentioned that he has that for the lift
like their larvae panel type of another
different buddy goes to the hotel
apartments people of montage and dinner
oya so what one of the problem trees
even if you this was that a mystical
down into a construction is like
building our do it only generates
polynomial size drop polynomial time
means potential size class I described
it polynomial time since I can do it but
not with a ménage à la Banque and what
they did gosh I'm de la voglia was
massage exact solitude just be
exponential what bounder came about this
extremity an time something that's small
but it's not poly log is due to the
Oakland okay we got into the thing you
know what's the saying that size doesn't
matter just the quality right so with
the donkey robotics fun until we just
one revolution no I'm joking for the I
that's I didn't I was not very aware of
this paper
other questions so how do these lips
compose and then how does a gay left
forward by gay that differ from a case
squarely you mean the 2k lift okay
squared yeah sorry um uh I think like I
mean not all k squared lifts would be
like combination of two operations so
the other way if you take it to lift
let's say all four lifts are not you
know either I don't know how to explain
it maybe picture would be better
yeah i guess i'm not even surf picture
is very better but not all for lethal
combinations of earth too late hey maan
Singh like in terms of expansion so oh
so you mean how if we repeat the
operation what happened so I mean like
so if you do one k square lift so can
the expansion be much better than doing
a k let followed by a cable oh I mean
the other way at random you mean yeah I
mean if you look if you lose nothing you
know if you- since there existed if that
preserves our management bound then it
makes no difference in some sense you
can get as good expansion with either
operation but if you if you do it
randomly I don't know
hold up an estoppel
I think it's 415 far 15 right